non seulement les sept une très belle
esthétique non seulement n'y a pas de
blasphème mais ça va beaucoup plus loin
que ça elle montre la progression de
l'église catholique ce qui est très
intéressant très important je rappelle
que le pape françois s'est prononcé en
faveur de l'union civile pour les
homosexuels c'est une grande première un
sou jean paul ii il ya encore pas si
longtemps il ne connaissait même pas
l'existence des homosexuels donc au
contraire je trouve que c'est une
avancée très intelligente c'est une très
belle et très intelligente très
progressiste et je suis mais tellement
choqué par le sondage que d'avoir 80
portant des gens qui sont choqués parce
que moi je ne peux pas je ne peux pas ne
pas corrélées le fait que les gens qui
sont choqués par cette une au fond d'eux
ils ne sont pas tout simplement s'il n'y
a pas tout simplement arland
d'homophobie
vous
me taxez d'homophobe moi oui mais vous
êtes fous pourquoi c'était assez d'ego
là n'avaient pas salut pour retirer
ce que tu fais à iriba des gens qui ne
vont pas voir bilal à vous la libye a
représenté peut-être dans la région
j'espère que vous montrez nous devrions
dépasser votre petite pensée pensée le
plus gros dégueulasse non mais ça c'est
des gâteaux de jockey julien lacroix si
je suis encore pourquoi c'est choquant
parce que la religion pour moi je vais
vous le dire j'en ai marre de vos
discours policé de la voiture pour moi
c'est l'un team et j'en ai marre qu'on
expose la religion et j'en ai marre je
ne veux pas qu'on expose sa dans les
gares je ne veux pas d'image religieux
dans les gars je vous le dis dans les
gars on se transporte il ya plein de
gens on n'a pas à m'imposer de la
religion dans une gare c'est ça c'est
interdit l'accès
j ai envie d'elle et s'était
j'adore têtu arrêter d'avoir bien sûr
marketing parce que vous êtes géniaux
pour ça m
tdk tous les propos que tu te le dise
ce qu'il a mais ça ne donne pas le droit
de faire ça et là des passagers droit je
dis ce que je le rate choix gil j étais
pas parce qu'on met la cc c'est
dégueulasse et paypal et sans bon sens
même pas lui dire ça y'a pas 80% des
gens quand ils disent que les filles
étaient pas que sont d'un avis opposé
quand je prends le train de voir là une
wheel à l'assainir une de têtu pour la
religion catholique pardon vivre à
cent pour cent avec mathieu merci à
force de lutter contre l'intolérance on
devient
facile versées mais c'est très facile
les idées qui sont grands maintenant
alors fait des gueulards et soma thomas
on va se calmer parce que thomas un
petit peu de douceur dans un monde de
brutes et vivre c'est ringard et il est
soudé et tout doux le magazine thomas
vous êtes vous avez réussi votre cou etc
mais c'est la presse mais je viens quand
notre but nous fait en sorte que ce soit
une qui soit belle il m'arrive quelque
chose je sois intelligent qui marque et
qui soit acheté une fille née pour que
l'ancien sun à vue parce que deere ce
derrière c'est une on a quand même tout
un dossier sur le harcèlement scolaire
sur lequel bilal lutte avec nous on a on
a une âme ont plein de contenus on a
d'autres personnalités de l'année qui
ont été nommés
dans le dossier voilà c'est l'idée c'est
quand même c'est un magazine et ces gens
j'en parlais tout à l'heure à mathieu
parce qu'on est revenu aussi sur la
polémique sur est-ce que bilal a saigné
représentent les gays ou pas et on en
revient là dessus dans le magazine
l'idée c'est de faire un pont en fête
entre les gens on n'est pas là du tout
pour diviser les croyants des non
croyants les homos des noms un mot les
garçons virgin les garçons folle bilal
justement c'est ça qui l'incarnent hyper
bien et qu'il a incarné dans une
émission de populaire
c'est que justement enfin on n'a plus à
choisir aujourd'hui la représentation
gay elle est multiple lgbt elle est
multiple et donc bilal cantine quand il
fait ça danse mais la première dans ce
jeu facile vous souvenez la première
danse le tableau sur sial quand ils
arrivent et qui défoncent la porte sur
le plateau est qui et qui fait sa
première annonce qui est extraordinaire
d'ailleurs il l'a refaite au dernier
prime c'est ça qui dit en fait c'est
cette espèce de libération quand même
que mathieu n'avait pas à son époque
mais moi j'avais pas à mon époque je
suis entre les deux est en fait
aujourd'hui voilà la représentation à
les multiples et plurielle et en fait
l'idée vous avez reçu à nice le jeune
qui avait été agressée de 17 ans
assureront
le message et s'adresse à ces jeunes là
leur dire qu'en fait
aujourd'hui il ya plus il ya plus de y'a
plus de manières d'être un garçon normal
et plus manière d'être une fille normale
en fait on est comme on est